good morning everybody thanks for being
here this is another seminars and quite
a series that we have been organizing
and actually I want to take the
opportunity to thank Issa Bell for
following up on the seminars if you have
any idea for your own to present or any
speaker you think should come and give a
seminar you can always float the idea
today we invited Luke don dava
ludendorff is a very esteemed colleague
with whom we have been working over the
past years in a very fruitful
collaboration between CIMMYT and simba
stuff when you see some of the numbers
about publications coming out of the
long term trial infrastructure the long
term trials we have here in in Mexico
part of those publications come from
student collaborations that we have been
doing together with Simba stuff and
Luke's research team what I always say
is the uniqueness is Luke has a lot of
nice ideas nice research tools that we
don't have and we have the long term
trials that can actually be the
background or the can generate a story
to buy through using those that those
insights that are way more upstream than
what we are doing
Luke is a very long and recognized
career he started its its work at
university university of lurvin
dan was quite some time active in Rotom
step and finally landed in Mexico in
Simla stuff where he's still leading one
of the most important research teams on
carbon nitrogen cycling and recently
micro organism processes but I'm sure he
will explain that way better than I can
do so thank you and let's give a round
of applause
[Applause]
good morning good morning and thanks for
coming
I try
relations but okay to give certain
characteristics to bacteria I don't know
if soap actress or important in that it
might be competition it might be
predictors are not collaboration between
friend institutes some younger
researchers working we already it's
rather a good collaboration I'm quite
proud of it
we have now 31 published peer-reviewed
manuscripts we've got seven hundred
forty-five citations some Morpher these
citations come from some very important
papers of Braun Road we have an index of
14 so I'm quite pleased with this
collaboration we have quite a lot of
other papers ready to submit okay we
know that agriculture practices affect
yields so characteristics we studied
some of these Elberton and Obregon but I
focus mostly pitfall in Elberton so in
sole characteristics abdominal pattern I
mentioned it immediately I got to
replicated plots so if you do an
analysis statistical analysis
you get problems because the variation
is rather great so often you see
clear-cut effects that they are not
significant so yeah some of the problem
that's one of the commands of the last
paper that we submit doesn't even know
it is to accept it but this is a command
I often receive we know but I'm a bit
worried about because it returns and
returns that's why obregón is that if we
want to get some soul samples and
extract DNA time becomes difficult and
if we want to expect
Aaron aid and it's even more okay but
these differences especially which have
a large effect on carbon nitrogen
mineralization this is a very simple
representation of the AI robic
incubation we do who got some soul which
are carbon dioxide and we measure in the
soil mineral M and now recently we saw
to extract a DNA to see what is
happening there another command that I
was not really aware but if you start to
work with bacteria then you have
non-parametric data I've never well did
a lot of research on soul
characteristics parametric but bacteria
if you count they're nonparametric and
again if you try to do some analysis
than yeah significant difference is
rather difficult to obtain because
nonparametric or more stringent if I can
say it all that okay so I said I would
mention the problems really these are
some results of carbon and nitrogen
mineralization you see not a lot of
differences between your treatments
although you have a difference in carbon
content and I compare that with ballpark
and Rothamsted where after how long as
it's more than hundred and sixty years
you really have a big difference in in
carbon carbon content is extremely
different I just want to mention you
know that maybe Jenkins have published a
paper on micro biomass carbon there's no
replicator broad book so if you look at
the data on his original paper then
there's no replicates there
additionally he includes soil and you
look at the line so but anyway I think a
very important paper but I have some
questions anyway we didn't detect a big
difference in carbon nitrogen
mineralization we did some measurements
also in the field we did that quite a
while ago and that was one of the
problems we faced when separate his
paper on carbon carbon dioxide emission
tonightís outside the mission the median
emissions that reviews pointing out you
only have two replicants okay
conservation agriculture possession but
okay you have these data you have these
differences so what is the effect of
these different on microbial populations
and this is a principal component
analysis and it's a you try to get all
your data on bacterial groups you try to
correlate them or whatever so a
separation between permanent vets
between conventional birds and what do
you get in in conventional vets you get
copy of drops fresh organic material
consumed it that they're graded them in
ER allows it to organisms that neutral
depleted its might be questionable as a
word because normally it has more to do
with nutrients down the foreground
epithelial but Auto for organic material
so if there is a microbiologist followed
up using that because some people are
very
yep Fermi could the agriculture
practices do you affect our markable
populations as I meant to permanent bats
they favor these groups which are only
go trough stat prefer nothing this is
the opposite
they prefer our nutrient rich this
should be reversed but anyway and then
we have conventional bats where we get
these organisms that prefer organic rich
environments why because if you have
conventional bets then you deal on top
ok sampling in 2012 2014 we'll get the
same results permanent bats preferred by
oligotrophic preferred they are favored
and if you go to conventional practices
conventional
um I always have questions is this for
real
do you have changes over time or my
results correct because your was a
problem often and what do I mean by
technique the when we did these first
analysis we had clones we had about 150
sequences of DNA and then we went to a
biro which is about a hundred thousand
sequences and now we go to Illumina and
we can talk about whatever you want 400
million two hundred so the question is
always there's an evolution okay now so
what we start experiment is here trying
salt samples over the year
and we want to look at population we try
to look at certain processes also
because it's one of the critiques you
can have on this work it's very
descriptive descriptive what this is all
about what you're really doing what is
the importance of all this and I will
say we try to start with getting the
techniques right and then we can start
to focus on some questions we have so
I'll mention some some questions at the
end of my talk but we want to focus on
on or nitrification and functionality
functionality are all RNA from a soul is
very difficult if you look at literature
you will find some papers on it but very
little problem is solo conditions and we
are very lucky that Obregon we succeed
in extracting Parana in Elberton forget
about it so you check the literature
it's the same week I mentioned bacteria
because extract or amplifying DNA from
fungi
Ryota is not so easy RK are we can do it
but it's a borderline so look at the
literature you will see some papers but
if you try to compare because NL in we
published a paper on fungi in Sonora and
microscopic eukaryota there's nothing to
compare it really somewhere it's okay
you have some but microscopic areata
very little okay if we have the question
about copier tropes and not of Stan my
idea was we got organic material if we
got organic me too available
we'll get some copy at Rose the writers
is normally organic carbon so what we're
trying to do all of these two behaving
in fear there's a lot of organic comedy
correct environments and also we apply
organic material crop residue to the
soil who is going to degrade eat an
organic material okay this is still a
recent and I haven't gone into all the
details but we did we met pollution
vegetative flowering gratefully so the
Pope's whole versus free this dynamics a
bit and then again they saw a lot of
rolling track development I with sass
and people convinced me that error it's
much better it is a magnificent tool but
it takes some time first to adjust to it
because sass is very straightforward
errors it's strange if you're not used
to it another problem see with I can do
this dis graph so well the results were
obtained in our eye and then put it in
Excel because I don't like the graphs
but you have about six or set packages
that can do this
and it's I get lost sometimes that's
easy it's straightforward towards the
same but to edit it's all these
biological techniques they don't exist
and in error you've got all these
updates
well daily I think so my advice is
people really want to want to work in
bio informatics go to arrow or fight
them I don't know fight them because
they're trying to convince me also to
start working in frightened I don't know
pursue me I will end up doing it but
anyway but then we get we get some clear
changes again in population in the
rhizosphere so are they holds more or
less it's there in in error sure if it
will all give better results but and
this is also very recent although I
think the program of this was they
started to write it when we were in
Oakridge they mentioned it this is where
you've got your bacteria identified with
ribosome al DNA sorry
and then you try to link these
populations to functions and that is
very interesting because although as you
go six hundred or thousand species lobby
hell what are they doing okay I know
Posse lose and I know so don't wanna
know akise and I know that but this
becomes interesting now I think that
Bala ping it because Aaron R is not so
easy to extract but I hope we can link
this with Erina ah this is he
I think of Tillich but I said it's just
I did it two days ago and then this is
another experiment - from these are
Cubase over time so if you see these
seven and fourteen normally we have
about 260 250 data points and then you
see here we are added being material and
this is on the mend it and then you see
that the beam the population is a shift
in pollution the story is I apply
organic material and there's a shift in
my population okay
as I said we can confirm Earth as always
once you get some answers they define
certain groups as being oligo troughs
and certain groups being copy of troughs
and then you you compare RT no bacteria
this group what is it micro focus area
and then you've got here Gail Alessia
and then you see these are favored by
organic material you apply and the
others not so yeah
you
so I think it would be rather difficult
to say that one bacterial group has
these characteristics I have to mention
when we go to species in bacteria then
we talk about 97% of similitude
similarly to dia we differ from
chimpanzees I think zero three percent
so what are we talking about really okay
but we are aware of this problem but we
should sometimes not forget it okay
as I mentioned these groups are very
easy to isolate so they are well
described but in a soil they are
normally not that important only three
percent of them and we got the other
bacillus of five percent so what is all
the rest do we one of the other problems
when we write these papers than normally
we mentioned about 15 groups at the
maximum and normally you found between
500 and thousand sinners so what all the
rest is doing we don't know and we don't
even want to talk about it because we
would go the pit get a paper off I don't
know how many pages but anyway so would
you the question was would sort
characteristics affect our behavior of
groups when we apply ionic materials who
we apply organic material in one system
permanent pets so we would hope that
this group which is acido bacteria ie
this is a very important group but we
don't know actually what it is doing and
then you see in employment that's when
you apply beam material their relative
abundance increases when you apply it to
a conventional but it's an effect or so
characteristic so we wanted to have some
sort of a bit more diverse to see how
different bacterias group respond to and
this we used to janaba and we used to
take
Coco and now this is quite nice so you
get a complete separation of your
different groups oh yeah one of the
problems I have is with economical
correlations when I do a principal
component analysis it's very nice
I go to canonical and it's not so nice
so my explanation is there is a factor
of defining this that I can't or I don't
measure it or is it that it's important
or its interaction between my
populations in the given environment but
I mean I said I would mention the
problems I see but okay I think we can
on this system and the different
ecosystems now you have the chinampa
barton Texcoco i Tyrael how are these
groups respond Tyrael and then you see
Tillett it's increasing why it gives the
organic material that's very well known
but then you start to see these groups
like oh think I missed that one this
which is rather well known and normally
it is a copy of drove however and this
system index KOCO one outlaw organic
material it participates in the
degradation of the organic material and
when our look hotel our tongue
not at all so conclusion these groups
adapt themselves or they add them at a
bullet metabolic capacity but the
environment the competition with other
groups defines how they respond yeah
so what we made a little
which organisms fit along a gradient so
we apply here some organic material and
we measured populations they want they
freely 7 14 28 256 and then you see the
groups that were favored their relative
abundance increase Allah - and they've a
good button down we see it in normal
basileus and some step two misses so
long yeah but you see there are
different groups it or faith or okay I
think I remember if I remember correctly
teacher said that theory and soil
normally keep genetic capacity they
don't shed so much of the capacity as
you will see in the reactor or in my
stomach genes in so this is again three
systems in material they get a shift in
your population okay
as I mentioned very well very nice you
got beautiful
bcoz you say oh we've got a shift but
can we learn for all this first of all I
think cooking techniques to specific
questions are one of the specific
questions we were trying to address now
is in Obregon it's a problem with sewing
that my nation plant emerges and plan to
stand decreased on the dry sowing but
not in wet conditions so we retreat them
with four pesticides or herbicides or
whatever insecticides fungicides done so
we assume it is a problem there with so
I think with all these techniques we now
have we try to look if it's really a
biological problem or facing ok
well that's not that difficult but this
is not that easy so conditions there are
some people extracting method anomic
sore where you pay a lot extract all the
DNA and then you'll know is everything
yeah it's rather cost costs a bit but
then you need and I'll mention that
later on when you need to computer power
and your knowledge to all these species
of 300 or 100 DNA spares to link them
that's not that easy neither but anyway
were working on as I mentioned as and
then another study we started this to
look at our populations why do we look
at different years were related to trace
gas emission greenhouse gas emission
nitrous oxide why do we focus on like
two fires and not on the United occasion
and all that many so we try to focus on
something that is Raleigh's study
additionally the genes or the yeah the
proteins involved in the process or
rather limited however for instance mor
which mon IAM mono oxygenase on or i
thought there was one now they're
already three different types so if you
want to look at these things these
processes you have to consider all the
possible genes so we're looking at we
are looking at permanent as conventional
burnt and then we have minus and plus we
want to measure this this is a first
preliminary experiment with ammonium to
these different sites and what we when
applied in the field that then you see
that a lot of oxidation of ammonium so
you have a rather vivid or active
notifier population which is not that
yeah
okay we want to measure we've measured
that we want to measure these gases we
want to measure biomass we go for
microbial structure nitrifiers this is
not that complicated as I mentioned you
already have three of them I don't know
how many I have of these but then we
want to if you can 90% of the activity
is normal activity of the organisms it's
not related to the process you're
studying got a bit of a needle and not
think so
it's too evident so we're trying to work
on that um one of the things I haven't
mentioned yet but I think with all the
changes in techniques we have what I
mentioned it we start 150 clones then we
went to a hundred thousand and now I
don't know how many to two hundred
million you need a bit of computer power
and we only starting so we will start
now since yesterday I think finally
after two years of negotiating we can
have a new option within the department
which will focus on bioinformatics
statistics and supercomputing one of the
problems I see in statistics personally
if time series I mean if you have a
change over time how do you compare this
population what we normally do what
Richard Webster always told me you just
take them in and you compare the mean
and there will be enough and forget
about all the rest but I think we need
it some some just that supercomputers
simply to get your make the genome meet
a genome together bioinformatics yeah
there's a lot of dispute about the
systems you've got your secrets and then
you have different system
verify or check identify the organisms
it belonged to and so you have sir NAL's
that say we want that system Europeans
normally go for the European system
America the American system and but
anyway that's another of the questions
we have and then another thing we will
try to do is we did a lot of these
experiments organic material copier
troughs oligotrophic you want to get it
all together it's about 20 experiments
we want to compare and see if all these
data we have some bitty bit of meta data
mining see we can get something out okay
that's or at the moment I must admit as
you can see this is not my work cover a
lot of people and I haven't mentioned
them all but would like to fight them
one of the advantages I think with the
Mexico we have a lot of people that's
for sure a lot of very enthusiastic
people very capable people funding is
not always that easy but ok we get along
and we have no access is to booster
sophisticated equipment but ok these
sequences we Santa Marta micro gent
Korea about the German group who now
extract DNA from soil from our ancestors
and have you read about that that now
they can extract DNA from so because lbn
a doesn't agree date and so so you it is
preserved so we if you look at the under
talus where they walked yeah we can find
traces of this DNA only mention it the
amount of soil you meet to do this is
not 20 grams like you do in the bottom
but a huge amount and what these sorry
these Germans have they developed a
robot so you can assess so
process an enormous amount of what we
have the people they have the robot we
have been 20th time robot will be cheap
all the rest will be rather expensive
Belen I would be very - for the field
experiment I think what Brom mentioned
is is true it's a unique yeah
a unique experiment when I answer these
question two replicates I always say
it's the only field experiment in the
tropics that I have access to okay there
- replicates but well maintained
experiments for more than 25 years
correct bro don't find them so if you
will study these things okay it might be
useless I'm not sure then you need
something you can rely on it's well done
because if you go into the field and we
compare whatever little bot done what we
compare forests the variation is huge
you know if you don't know what they did
so I am grateful it and also when the
money thought they were more than
willing to help me I am in depth to see
this stuff for the infrastructure and of
course corners it was very generous with
funding us I think that's it yep
[Applause]
things look and even that I was involved
in in the work I still got some new
ideas by seeing it presented like that
so as always you keep us on our toes any
questions from the from the audience
please use the microphones because we
have over I don't know how many people
but several connected via the webinar so
if you can use the microphone even I
look hi
very interesting I I think I might have
missed when you collect your soil
samples to do your extractions what
depth or from what part of the soil are
those soils we normally we normally work
on the topsoil layer why we do that is
because we hope with the biggest
diversity I know there are papers
published that you have to be careful
with the proof well I I'm well aware of
that but it's it all has to do with
where do you want to focus on if I said
200 samples to analyze if I would go
into profiles tonight I get lost it's a
little always trying to 0 to 20 0 to 15
C to 10 to 20 it depends it depends a
bit yeah but nobody's here written I
don't know you could go back to the soil
tests of the three different locations
yeah I don't know if I thought this KOCO
with a pH is it to acetic acidic pH 9 is
not here at this station right what this
oh no no no oh sorry oh yes okay I have
to explain this because you you have
this differences in in air bottom we see
a difference and so we see an effect of
what we do on our population so to to
stress to to go in an excess of
variation we were too
Sol's in the area it's a chinampa it's
in Xochimilco Texcoco you you got nine
point four which is not a lot because in
texcoco we have ten point five but we do
not do go to be too extreme yeah it's a
tech school it's it like yeah yeah and
and you have a huge salinity also the
lot of studies of context Coco that's
why I sorry say yeah yeah sorry
one last question no no what's your view
on these bio fertilizers that are
dealing with these bacteria well this is
not my well it's personal but I'm not
the only one who would say that I
remember David Jenkinson say and I
remember Martin Alexander saying that I
agree completely I think it would be
very difficult to there that there are
two reasons first of all you have an
equilibrium you have a system in
equilibrium you apply something
organisms second if you have a soil you
apply it how are you going to apply it
where you need it
I can imagine you fertilize a seat and
then you hope we did some experiments we
did an experiment bath serum and it was
fantastic it was the best we had an
effect for one month on the roots and
that was it I'm actually doing
experiment with mace one of the farmers
who has this brilliant system of bio
fertilizer and and we sterilized is
consortium and in the beginning the
sterilized consortium gave better
results than the consortium there's
another reason why I'm very skeptical
for this experiment we took the
literature check the literature and it
tells you quite a lot where was it
published which journals was published I
get very doubtful
I remember in Berlin Berlin but it was
cut off flocek with also superior in
brazil and i had a positive result so
they published it and it could never
repeat it so I am but the expendable
doing is we using these techniques we
have now to look more at survived so we
have this consortium will characterize
it will see what is happening problem is
always okay I'm working in green house
because if I do it in a field and again
you know the problems in the field
people do thinks he don't know one of
the other that's the reason why I prefer
to work with cement we started to work
with somebody yeah in route to correct
our room I don't remember the name
typically be bugged Apache I don't
remember the village and and you try to
collaborate and then they call you and
they say only we fertilized yeah do you
have sample so you can't and that's also
one of the questions of reviews why did
you do it in a greenhouse yeah can't say
I can't work in this because it's not
like Europe remember we measured some
trace gases in Chiapas and su Chiapas
and we we left our PVC tubes in the
field they stole them and we were
communicating constantly with local
people I yeah it's one of the reasons
also why I think field experiments are
similar brilliant and that we do some
some field some lab experiments it's
very difficult to justify to review says
yeah ok yeah
just a comment we actually also have a
field trial that's been going on for 20
years and San Luis Potosi haha at any
flop station so might be interesting
also to do some investigation there also
evaluate conservation agriculture
minimal village and conventional system
and two replications okay okay what what
kind of soil is it so it's if we can
extract that or an A then that , meter
because it's rather copper notes no no
no no it's it's it's not it's not even
no sorry this is this it's not even to
do with the type of soil it is it is at
random we had in the beginning for
instance in in Elberton we sampled or
you said you're trying to extract DNA
you got 9 replicate where you've got
treatments and all of sudden once all
you can't extract it whatever you do now
we optimize that on blah blah blah but
it's it's you you you if you go to
conferences or congresses that was one
at Broadway last year in December where
and then you hear the scene the same
questions
DNA nor the problem RNA proteins that
people huge map what kind of money
dedicated to extract proteins because
that's the final solution I mean DNA RNA
and proteins puppets and they got money
you know Europe it's 1 million euros but
you know what I mean it's these
techniques are not yet what they should
be but I think they're brilliant I love
it
I think Simon for your comment and
actually slowly are going to be ready to
be put in in this kind of this kind of
networks and taking advantage of off of
thinking all the PhD students that
actually have been connected to the work
and that I think that's something we
have to reactivate also in the in the
team to see how can we can they be a PhD
student working on
to see or so definitely nila
is working on that Yvonne is working on
attracting more students so I think
that's how we can keep this kind of work
going any more questions question over
there somebody else know somebody online
somebody online has a question now that
I was recently following a seminar
online I know how frustrated it is you
want to say something and nobody
remembers that you're actually hanging
on your computer no one time two times
last time no question Luke you other
question was a specific question you I'm
not I'm willing to investigate it but
the descriptive I think no because we've
done it I think we should we should
start using these techniques to really I
have a problem here can I can I answer
with my molecular biology I think so so
if you have questions more number yep
okay thank you very much look and I
think this is a clear example of
research research are in fact true
partnerships when I'm asked what is the
value of the long term drugs I just show
Luke's first slide with I don't know I
don't even remember more than 30 share
joint publications and 18 decks of 14
and that usually helps to convince them
more academically or oriented donors so
look thank you very much it has been a
brilliant partnership and there's more
to come in future
[Applause]
you